ALL OF THEM.
WE SEND THEM ALL OF GOD'S
BLESSINGS BE TUCKER, THANK YOU.
BUCKLE UP, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
EXPOSING THE DEEP STATE, WE'LL
GET TO ALL OF THIS MOMENTARILY.
COMPLICATED, BUT SIMPLE ON THE
OTHER HAND.
GLENN BECK IS HERE TONIGHT.
GOING TO WEIGH IN ON THE DIRE
DANGERS OF SOCIALISM AND HOW
IT'S REAL.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN SEASON IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS NOW OFF TO A DISASTROUS,
PATHETIC START.
SOCIALISM, OPPRESSIVE TAXES,
OPEN BORDERS.
OH, AND POST BIRTH ABORTIONS.
A PARTY THAT'S BECOME EVEN MORE
RADICAL.
PER USUAL, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA?
THEY ARE PROVIDING THE COVER,
THE SUPPORT THESE CANDIDATES,
THE EXTREME IDEAS, VERY SHADY
PATHS EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
WE'LL INVESTIGATE ALL OF THIS.
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
"HANNITY WATCH" ON THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST 2020 DEMOCRATS.
RIGHT NOW AT THIS HOUR, OVER A
DOZEN PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFULS HAVE
ALREADY THROWN THEIR HATS IN THE
RING.
MANY MORE ARE EXPECTED TO
DECLARE BEFORE THE YEARS END.
IN THE LATE LAST WEEK, FORMER
FAILED SENATORIAL CANDIDATE
ROBERT FRANCIS O'ROURKE,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS BETO BOZO
O'ROURKE, HE ANNOUNCED HIS
CANDIDACY.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY DO
WHAT THEY ALWAYS DO.
THEY FALL IN LOVE WITH BETO.
ROBERT FRANCIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE'S JUST AN EXTRA ORDINARY
GUY.
>> IN VIBRANCY, YOUTHFULNESS TO
HIM.
HE HAS A MESSAGE WHICH IS
LARGELY CHEERFUL.
>> HAD A WAY OF SPEAKING
INSPIRATIONAL HE BUT ALSO REALLY
SERIOUSLY, LAYING OUT THE
STAKES.
>> WHAT HE HAS TO START WITH IS
A CHARISMA THAT YOU JUST CAN'T
MANUFACTURE.
>> HE'S GOT THE SON AND HIS
FACE, LOOKS SUNNY, OPTIMISTIC,
NOT THE INDOOR BUREAUCRAT
SITTING IN THE DESK IN SOMEWHERE
SITTING IN THE DESK IN SOMEWHER.
>> IT'S LIKE A JESUS CHRIST
SUPERSTAR SEEING PEOPLE IN FRONT
OF HIM.
IN THAT MOMENT, HE WAS OWNING
IT.
>> Sean: YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE A DEJA VU HERE?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE'VE SEEN THIS
KIND OF CHEERLEADING FROM THE
SUPPOSEDLY UNBIASED MAINSTREAM
MEDIA BEFORE?
WE DID.
THEY WERE IN LOVE WITH
BARACK OBAMA.
JUST A REMINDER, WELCOME WE WENT
INTO OUR ARCHIVES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE CROWD.
THE THRILL, THE HOPE.
CROWD SURGED TOWARDS HIM.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT AN AMERICAN
POLITICAL PHENOMENON.
>> YOU ARE THE EQUIVALENT OF A
ROCK STAR.
>> THE BUS RIDE ON THE SNOWY
ROAD TO LEBANON NEW HAMPSHIRE, I
SHOWED HIM THIS WEEK'S
"NEWSWEEK" OFF THE PRESSES.
>> HOW DOES THIS FEEL, OF ALL
THE HONORS THAT HAVE COME YOUR
WAY?
>> THE FEELING THEY GET WHEN
MOST PEOPLE GET, I GET THIS
FEELING THAT MY LEG.
I DON'T HAVE THAT TOO OFTEN.
>> STUDY.
>> SERIOUSLY.
IT'S A DRAMATIC OFFEND.
>> IN SOME WAYS, BARACK OBAMA IS
THE FIRST PRESIDENT SINCE
GEORGE WASHINGTON TO BE TAKING A
STEP DOWN INTO THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> Sean: THIS LOVE AFFAIR
PERSISTED FOR EIGHT LONG YEARS
AND BEYOND AND IT WAS SO BAD
THAT THIS PROGRAM WAS ONE OF THE
VERY FEW ONLY SHOWS TO ACTUALLY
DO THE REAL VETTING OF FUTURE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BARACK OBAMA.
REMEMBER, ON THIS PROGRAM, WE
SHOW YOU OBAMA'S TIES TO THE
RADICAL, UNREPENTANT WEATHER
UNDERGROUND DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
BILL AYRES AND INFINITY DOOR
AND?
ON THE SHOW, REVEALED THE TRUE
NATURE OF OBAMA'S LONGTIME
PASTOR 20 PLUS YEARS JEREMIAH
WRIGHT AND THE CHURCH OF GD
AMERICA, ROOTED IN BLACK
LIBERATION THEOLOGY WHICH WE
EXPLAINED TO YOU.
AND FRANK MARSHALL DAVIS, ACORN,
A LINSKY, COMMUNITY ORGANIZING.
ONCE AGAIN, TO VET THE 2020
CANDIDATES, WHICH WE PROMISE
WILL BE DOING NIGHTLY AND/OR
PREDICTIONS OF A FAILED PROP,
OBAMA PRESIDENCY ROOTED IN THESE
RADICAL VIEWS TURNED OUT TO BE
MORE ACCURATE THAN WE WOULD'VE W
MORE ACCURATE THAN WE WOULD'VE S
MORE ACCURATE THAN WE WOULD'VE E
MORE ACCURATE THAN WE WOULD'VE D
FOR FOR OUR COUNTRY.
IF THE MEDIA HAD DONE THEIR JOB,
AMERICA MIGHT HAVE AVOIDED THAT
DISASTER.
THEY WERE OBAMA'S CHEERLEADERS
EVERY SINGLE DAY, EVEN ON THE
RIDICULOUS HUNDRED $50 BILLION
IRANIAN DEAL.
WELL, WE CAN SEE HISTORY IS NOT
REPEATING.
THE LATEST CONTROVERSY
SURROUNDING REUTERS AND ROBERT
FRANCIS O'ROURKE ON FRIDAY.
WE LEARNED THAT ONE OF THEIR
REPORTERS, REUTERS, SAT FOR
ALMOST TWO YEARS ON AN
EMBARRASSING STORY ABOUT
O'ROURKE'S TIME AS A RENEGADE ON
LINEBACKER UNTIL AFTER HIS HOTLY
CONTESTED RACE WITH TED CRUZ.
IN FACT, A REPORTER NAMED JOSEPH
MAN ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT
WITH BETO BOZO TO DELAY HIS
DAMNING STORY.
IF IT SEEMS LIKE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS WORK
TOGETHER TO WIN ELECTIONS AS ONE
TEAM?
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY DO.
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS SHIELDING
DEMOCRATS FROM EMBARRASSMENT BY
SPIKING OR DELAYING CERTAIN
REPORTS, ALL WHILE STICKING IT
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP EVERY SECOND,
EVERY MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF
EVERY DAY, THE MATTER HOW SHAKY
THE STORY, HOW WEAK THE
SOURCING, IF ANY SOURCING.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE BUSBY
DEPOSITOR'S LATEST
FAKE NEWS EMBARRASSMENT.
NOW THAT BOZO IS RUNNING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY,'S REPORT IN
REUTERS HAS BEEN PUBLISHED.
ITS CONTENTS ARE DOWNRIGHT
SHOCKING.
AS WE CONTINUE TO VET THE
CANDIDATES ON OUR HANNITY WATCH,
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE OUTLETS,
AS A TEENAGER O'ROURKE HELPED
FOUND ONE OF AMERICA'S OLDEST
HACKING GROUPS CALLED "THE CULT
OF THE DEAD COW."
DURING HIS TIME IN THE HACKING
COMMUNITY, OLD BETO AND HIS
ONLINE FRIENDS INSTALL
VIDEO GAMES, STOLE LONG DISTANCE
PHONE SERVICE FOR HIS DIAL-UP
MODEM, GAIN SOME VARIOUS HACKING
EFFORTS IN THE 1980s.
HE HAD THE NAME "PSYCHEDELIC WAR
LOAD," AND BOZO FREQUENTLY
POSTED UNUSUAL, BIZARRE,
STRANGE, FRIGHTENING WRITINGS ON
GROUP MESSAGE BOARDS INCLUDING
CLASSIFYING CERTAIN WOMEN AS
"SLUTS," ULTRA TREDIES WERE
"SCENE SLUTS" THAT MANY MEN --
O'ROURKE WROTE THE BEST WAY TO
DEAL WITH THESE GIRLS WAS TELL
THEM THAT THEY ARE UGLY.
O'ROURKE ALSO POSTED A VIOLENT,
BIZARRE MURDER FANTASY, ONE DAY
I WAS DRIVING HOME FROM WORK I
NOTICED TWO CHILDREN CROSSING
THE STREET AND AS I NEARED THE
YOUNG ONES, I PUT ALL OF MY
WEIGHT ON MY RIGHT FOOT, KEEPING
THE ACCELERATOR PEDAL ON THE
FLOOR UNTIL I HEARD THE CRASHING
OF TWO CHILDREN ON THE HOOD AND
THE SHARP CRY OF PAIN FROM ONE
OF THE TWO.
PRETTY SICK, UGLY, TWISTED, DARK
STORY.
GOES FROM THERE -- TO BE FAIR,
ROBERT FRANCIS WAS MUCH YOUNGER
AT THE TIME OF THIS DISTURBING
PUBLICATION.
BUT I ASK THIS QUESTION: I
WONDER IF THE MEDIA, THE LEFT, I
WONDER IF THEY'LL FOLLOW THE
CAVANAUGH STANDARD FOR BETA
O'ROURKE.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY POURED
THROUGH JUSTICE CAVANAUGH'S
HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOK, ALL IN
AN ATTEMPT TO DISQUALIFY HIM FRO
AN ATTEMPT TO DISQUALIFY HIM FRM
THE SUPREME COURT?
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
BETO, OR BOZO IN THAT CASE BID
THAT'S THEIR STANDARD FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
ONE STANDARD FOR LIBERALS, ONE
STANDARD FOR CONSERVATIVES.
IN FACT, THIS REPORT ABOUT BETO
HAS BARELY MADE A DENT IN THE
TRADITIONAL NEWS CYCLE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, O'ROURKE
OFFERED THIS HEARTFELT APOLOGY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE WAS A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT TODAY THAT SHARED THINGS I
HAVE WRITTEN AS A TEENAGER.
REALLY HATEFUL.
REALLY BAD STUFF.
I'M MORTIFIED TO READ IT NOW.
INCREDIBLY EMBARRASSED.
BUT I HAVE TO TAKE OWNERSHIP AND
UNDERSTAND THE WAY THAT IT MAKES
PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY READ THEM
NOW.
WHATEVER MY INTENTION WAS AS A
TEENAGER DOESN'T MATTER.
AND SO I THINK I'LL SPEAK FOR
MYSELF.
I HAVE TO LOOK LONG AND HARD AT
MY ACTIONS IN THE LANGUAGE THAT
I HAVE USED AND HAVE TO
CONSTANTLY TRY TO DO BETTER.
SPEWING NATURALLY IN THE
HYPERSENSITIVE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
O'ROURKE WAS ALSO FORCED TO
ISSUE SEVERAL OTHER APOLOGIES,
INCLUDING A JOKE ABOUT HIS WIFE
RAISING THEIR CHILDREN AND, OF
COURSE, HIS WHITE PRIVILEGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'LL BE MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL
IN GOING FORWARD IN THE WAY THAT
I TALK ABOUT OUR MARRIAGE, AND
ALSO THE WAY IN WHICH I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH OF THE
CRITICISM THAT I HAVE ENJOYED
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
ABSOLUTELY.
UNDENIABLE.
>> Sean: HERE WE GO.
YET ANOTHER WEAK DEMOCRAT
STARTING WITH APOLOGY TOURS.
MORE BAD NEWS FROM BOZO, THE
CROWD THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD IS
ABOUT TO GET EVEN BIGGER.
OVER THE WEEKEND, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT CRAZY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN ACCIDENTALLY ANNOUNCED
HIS RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THEN HE TOOK IT BACK.
NOT UNCOMMON FOR HIM.
>> I GET CRITICIZED.
I GET TOLD I'M CRITICIZED BY THE
NEW LEFT.
I HAVE THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
RECORD FOR ANYBODY RUNNING FOR
THE -- ANYBODY WHO WOULD RUN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I DIDN'T MEAN...
ANYBODY WHO WOULD RUN.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T WORK IN MY
STATE, THE SLAVE STATE, WITHOUT
A SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
REFERRED TO BARACK OBAMA AS,
WOW, STORYBOOKS, CLEAN AND
ARTICULATE.
WHETHER OR NOT HE RUNS FOR
PRESIDENT, HE'S USING HIS PUBLIC
STATUS MUCH LIKE THE CLINTON'S
TO RAKE IN MILLIONS.
FROM SIX-FIGURE SPEAKING GIGS TO
SEVEN-FIGURE BOOK DEALS, CRAZY
UNCLE JOE IS TURNING HIS HUMBLE
PUBLIC SERVICE INTO A GOLD MINE.
IF HE RUNS, BIDEN WOULD BE JUST
THE LATEST DEMOCRAT TO ENGAGE IN
CLASS WARFARE POLITICS, ALL
WHILE SITTING ON TOP OF A MOUND
OF CASH AND THE WORST RECORD OF
ANY POLITICAL TEAM, HIM AND
OBAMA, WE'VE SEEN IN OUR
LIFETIME.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
ON "20/20" POLITICS THROUGHOUT
THE SHOW AND ALSO THE YEAR.
BUT FIRST, WE HAVE TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO OUR REPORT ON
HANNITY WATCH ON THE DEEP STATE
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE BRAND-NEW INFORMATION.
WE SAW IT WITH A BRAND-NEW
"USA TODAY" SUFFOLK UNIVERSITY
POLL.
ONE HALF OF AMERICANS NOW
BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
IN FACT A VICTIM OF A WITCH HUNT
BEING CARRIED OUT BY ROBERT
MUELLER AND HIS MERRY BAND OF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS.
DOESN'T TAKE A GENIUS' TEAM OF
INVESTIGATORS TO REALIZE THAT
COLLUSION IS A HOAX.
IN FACT, ACCORDING TO DISGRACE
ONE TIME LEAD FBI INVESTOR GET A
PEWTER PETER STROZK, THEY SAY TE
PEWTER PETER STROZK, THEY SAY TS
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION WHEN
THE COUNCIL WAS ELECTED BUT
THAT'S AFTER THEY INVESTIGATED
FOR NINE STRAIGHT MONTHS BEFORE
THE APPOINTMENT OF MUELLER.
HERE WE ARE 670 DAYS AFTER THE
MUELLER PROBE, AND AS INTENSE AS
IT'S BEEN, STILL NO COLLUSION.
NONE.
ZERO.
NOTHING FOR IT YET, IT'S A
WITCH HUNT.
MEANWHILE, THANKS TO THE NEWLY
RELEASED DEPOSITION FROM ORRIN,
PAGE, STROZK, STEELE, NEW
DETAILS HOW A HIGH-RANKING
BUREAUCRATS TRY TO USE HILLARY
CLINTON'S PHONY, BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO TAKE DOWN
DONALD TRUMP.
WE NOW KNOW TONIGHT THAT
CHRISTOPHER'S
STEELE GAVE THE
ASSOCIATE TO A McCAIN
ASSOCIATE DAVID KRAMER.
SOMETIMES AT THE DIRECTION OF
STEELE HIMSELF WHO HATED
DONALD TRUMP SPREAD OF THE
DOSSIERS UNVERIFIED,
UNCORROBORATED CONTENTS TO 12
JOURNALISTS AT NINE DIFFERENT
NEWS OUTLETS.
TWO STATE TO PREVENT OFFICIALS,
INCLUDING ONE CONNECTED TO
JOHN KERRY.
WHY?
TO USE THE HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
MOLLY THAT MIKE
LIES TO INFLUENCE YOU, WE, THE
PEOPLE.
BEFORE THE ELECTIONS, TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF THAT
ELECTION AND WORSE.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
ACCORDING TO BRUCE ORR,
CHRISTOPHER WAS STILL HATED
DONALD TRUMP, DESPERATE TO
MALIGN HIM.
AS WAS HILLARY CLINTON.
AS WAS THE POPULAR ASHKELON.
DOJ, NOT RANK-AND-FILE.
AS WELL AS THE CORRUPT NEWS
MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY THAT RAN
WITH THESE LIES, NEVER VERIFIED
A THING.
UNVERIFIABLE BECAUSE IT WASN'T
TRUE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ALL KNEW, ALL
WERE TOLD THAT THIS IS
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED,
HILLARY PAID FOR IT, AND STEELE
HATED TRUMP, A PACK OF LIES,
THEY TRIED TO GET IT OUT TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
PROPAGANDIZING, YOU, MIA, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TOP DOJ AND FBI OFFICIALS, THOSE
ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT SAVED
HILLARY CLINTON FROM BEING
INDICTED.
SOMETHING THAT WOULD'VE HAPPENED
TO ALL OF US.
THEY WORKED ON HER BEHALF.
USE HER LIES TO COMMIT FRAUD ON
FISA COURTS, SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, BEFORE THE ELECTION
AND AFTER THE ELECTION, AND IT'S
ALL BECOMING CRYSTAL CLEAR
TONIGHT.
BUT THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING.
WHAT WE NOW HAVE IS THE
BEGINNING OF A CASCADE OF
INFORMATION AND MATERIALS THAT
WILL BE CORROBORATING EVERYTHING
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU THE
LAST TWO ERRICO
YEARS.
TONIGHT, I CAN TELL YOU, EXPECT
MORE RESERVATIONS ABOUT HOW THE
DOSSIER WAS WRITTEN, WHERE IT'S
INFORMATION WAS DERIVED, AND HOW
HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS INSIDE A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ABUSED THEIR
POWER TO HELP HILLARY GET
ELECTED AND THEN LATER TO TAKE